[Music]
we're heading to Arizona this weekend
for three days of PFT live some of the
guests that you will hear from just a
small sampling Bill's general manager
Brandon bean Packers GM Brian Gouda
kunst Colts coach Frank Reich Falcons
coach Dan Quinn Titans GM John Robinson
and new Dolphins head coach Brian Flores
but plenty more to come as we get ready
to go to Arizona and Peter look it's
combination of rule changes it's who's
gonna speak who's gonna be there what
are we gonna learn get give me something
you're looking forward to seeing hearing
witnessing in Arizona Mike on Tuesday
every year at the NFL owners meetings
the NFL coaches sit in a gigantic
ballroom at 7:15 in the morning
everybody gets breakfast and for one
hour the 32 NFL coaches it used to be 16
and 16 one on Monday and one on to one
group on Monday one on Tuesday but now
they do them all together so they have
them all together in a room and for one
hour you can go from table to table and
you can ask any coach anything on the
record that you want and and so I am
looking forward mostly at these league
meetings for the first time in 85 days
on Tuesday Mike Tomlin will sit with
reporters and he will have a lot to talk
about now I don't know how much he's
going to talk about it but there's three
basic topics one Antonio Brown to
Le'Veon Bell three Ben Roethlisberger
those are all topics that could last two
hours each and we're gonna have to
sausage casing them in to one hour so I
think probably mostly I'm looking
forward to Mike Tomlin sort of
reasserting his authority in control of
the Pittsburgh Steelers while trying to
eat breakfast that's what I always loved
about that you mentioned the sausage
casing there literally will be sausage
casing on the plate that never gets out
there's that picture of Bill Belichick
at that at that breakfast just drinking
the big old glass of orange juice and he
usually shows
like a half-hour late for it but yeah
Tomlin has avoided the media that's a
great call he's avoided the media
there's a lot to discuss and you know
there's fundamental things to discuss -
I would like to hear from Art Rooney the
second about whether or not they're
going to change their ways as it relates
to the structuring of contracts because
I still believe that if they would
guarantee money in the second year of a
deal
they'd still have lay beyond bail under
contract right now he would have signed
a long-term deal two years ago if they
would have guaranteed him the first year
and second year amounts of the franchise
tag the total would have been twenty six
point five four million if you fully
guarantee that by the way he got twenty
seven million fully guaranteed over two
years from the Jets if this still hasn't
done that two years ago he'd still be a
stealer he decide that contract but they
refuse stubbornly to put guaranteed
money beyond the first year and it cost
them their relationship with labor on
bail but he also Mike when you say that
he basically got the same guaranteed
money and I know this was not your
intent when you just said that they
ought he also missed out on after taxes
over eight million dollars in 2018 so
and that's money he'll never make and
and again it's one thing if he gets an
earl Thomas type contract okay because I
believe and we both believe that Earl
Thomas you could have knocked him over
with a feather when the Ravens gave him
thirty two million guaranteed after he
was gonna sign a one-year twelve million
dollar contract elsewhere
III mean that is that's the that's a -
Earl Thomas that was as he told me I was
shocked but but but anyway the one thing
about Le'Veon Bell you look at going
forward tremendous amount of pressure on
the New York Jets to be able to with a
lesser offensive line than he had in
Pittsburgh to be able to try to create
an offensive environment without at
least on the surface anyway that deep
threat capability maybe Sam Darnell does
it with Anderson and and with and with
the other new receivers he has but as of
right now you know there's a lot of
pressure on the Jets to create an
offense for Le'Veon Bell
is gonna work and you know ultimately
the biggest flaw in the entire Le'Veon
Bell analysis may have been that if he
had played last year and suffered a
serious injury he won't get paid on the
open market Earl Thomas has the twice
broken leg he got thirty two million
fully guaranteed Quan Alexander tore an
ACL he got fourteen and a half million
guaranteed at signing another thirteen
point two five million guaranteed for
injury in year two and and again I know
you want to preserve your body and get
your big payday and he did eventually
get his big payday he gave up the
fourteen and a half million last year in
gross pay to get the twenty seven
million in fully guaranteed money this
year so he kind of had a plan there but
maybe he could have had both even if he
had suffered an injury last year he
would have had he would have had both I
mean you know it's the old Mike Tyson
thing everybody has a plan until they
get punched in the face Le'Veon Bell
sort of got punched in the face by the
Steelers last year not budging on that
contract and he got let's not say
punched in the face this year but he did
get a left jab in the face in nobody
paying him an average of more than the
franchise fee and Mike listen this is
not anti Le'Veon Bell this is a you know
this has nothing to do with people
thinking that Le'Veon Bell is not
necessarily great this has to do with
one major factor in how football is
played as a game today in 2017 the NFL
Offensive Rookie of the Year was the
67th pick in the draft Alvin Kamara in
2017 the NFL rushing champion was the
86th pick in the draft
Kareem hunt of the Kansas City Chiefs
you can find runningback value down the
road that's why everybody is saying why
am i paying fifteen million a year for a
running back makes no sense whatsoever
let me pay fifteen million for a
position where there is virtual scarcity
versus the running back position where
there is always
a plethora of opportunities to sign guys
and send guys who will be twelve to
fifteen hundred yard players look at me
look at the Indianapolis Colts Colts
last year you know everybody said they
got a sign Le'Veon Bell why Marlin Mack
had eleven hundred and something yards
in twelve games last year so I mean I'm
not saying that Marlin Mac is Le'Veon
Bell I'm saying do you need Le'Veon Bell
they went on an incredible hot streak
with Marlin Mac so I just think that
it's not Le'Veon Bell ability it is the
position that didn't get him paid then
why why did the Steelers tag him twice
why give him 12.1 for 2017 and put 14
and a half million on the table for 2018
at some point you say no go hit the open
market and you're gonna get a lot less
than that and maybe will resign you for
a lot less than what's already out there
on the table
because he was there he was their guy
Mike and it was working great
other than the suspensions it was
working great he was a great player for
that offense and he was worth it to them
and so I mean and and really when you
think about it here's the way I look at
it's a 14.5 for one year if you were to
ask me last year if I were the
Pittsburgh Steelers did I think that was
a lot for lay beyond bill yes but do I
think paying a great player on your team
7% of your salary cap is overdoing it no
do I think that paying him 18 million a
year or whatever all this guaranteed
money over three or four years is a
waste and is wrong yes
but to me I still think if they paid him
last year he worked in tandem with James
Conner that that would have been it that
would have been a great match for them
did they end up needing it maybe could
he have made the difference in one or
two more games he said they would have
gone to a Super Bowl I doubt it but but
they would have been a better team
spending that money on Le'Veon Bell last
year Peter somebody else that I am
looking forward to hearing from Giants
co-owner John Mara
firmly believed that the Monday
conference call from Dave gentlemen the
GM of the Giants was intended to take
some of the focus off of Mara who will
always hold court on his way in it was
last year where he really as a practical
matter got the topic out in the open
that the Giants would trade Odell
Beckham jr. because he was so
exasperated by Beckham I'm done talking
about Beckham and I want to hear about
Beckham I just wonder whether Mehra
hoped that Gettleman press conference
would result in fewer questions about
what precisely the Giants plan is right
now because it sure doesn't seem like
they have one Peter I think their plan
is very simply you look at the history
of Dave gentlemen Dave gentlemen
believes that he wants to build both
lines that is the way he is
Dave gentlemen is you know is George
Young in the 80s that's what I think he
is and you know he is a guy who wants to
make sure that he can rush the passer
and stop the run and who can run the
ball that's what he wants to do now
maybe that's prehistoric football seems
that way to me but I believe that is
what he's going to do and Mike if he
doesn't take Dwayne Haskins at number
one the N and he has the chance to take
Dwayne Haskins and I don't know that he
will but if he doesn't take him that
confirms that because clearly that would
have been the second year in a row he
would have passed it in favor of the
running game and building the lot I
think it would be it would say was
building the lines I will be very
surprised if in those first three pit
those first three rounds and might think
about this you know I talked to Daniel
Jeremiah on my podcast a few weeks ago
talked to kuiper I've talked to and I
talked to NFL guys and they all not all
perfectly say this or vividly say this
but there is a sense that the real depth
in this draft is in the Patriots
wheelhouse they got six picks between 32
and 101 and if you look at where the
Giants are picking right now
6:17 two in the second and then one in
the third round you are going to see the
New York Giants in my opinion maybe by
trading down once who knows but you're
going to see them address those two
lines three times in those first five
picks
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports